previously on TV sins
[Music]
I know animation is tough guys but why
is the end table behind the couch now
when it was between them just a few
seconds ago you show us your concept of
good TV and wheel crap all over that TV
sends mission statement somehow ends up
in the script didn't snowball and the
other dogs in this universe leave in
episode two a lot of the Smiths still
have this bed out here sure it could be
that they're just too lazy to get rid of
it after a quick cutaway to Jerry it's
now gone so that's a continuity error in
at least one way and maybe even two you
can probably guess which way I'm leaning
how about Showtime extreme in a world
where man evolved from corn welcome to
the Rick and Morty improv show with all
the hits and misses and improv show
entails it'll be just like the everyday
programming on channel 62 in the movie
UHF the fact this gun was duct taped to
his back and yet the duct tape somehow
stays in place after he grabs it to pop
this other corner and doesn't even have
a kernel of truth to it what two corny
Letterman from a timeline where Jerry's
Famous they stumble upon shows that
directly relate to themselves on a TV
with infinite worlds and infinite shows
and I find that infant definitely
convenient no the other thing go back
really all right fine why would the TV
go back immediately to the guy eating
when Rick changed channels twice since
they ran across this disgusting ship
this episode is a treasure Trove of
quick hilarious visual gags like
bottomless baseballs or a version of
Game of Thrones where everyone's a
little person except Tyrion I've never
loved my pause button so much in my life
here these scan your retinas and let you
view parallel timelines and I happen to
be carrying this thing around with me at
all times check out this refrigerator
only two hundred dollars pretty
hilarious that because ants in his eyes
Johnson can't see he thinks the dryer is
a refrigerator but did anyone help him
shoot the commercial wouldn't someone
correct him that he's pointing at
Dreyer's his commercial isn't being shot
edited and broadcast live although that
would be quite the trick I've heard of
fire ants but are there fireproof ants
because those ants seem just fine
despite being engulfed in flames
[Music]
I don't see anything there's a chance
you weren't even born I thought the
headset scanned your retinas and matched
them with your parallel universe cell so
why would the headset go through
parallel universes where summer doesn't
exist also if these goggles also land on
realities you don't exist in they would
be rendered basically unusable with
infinitely possible universes the
chances of you landing on one you
actually exist in is infinitesimally
small a Mexican Armada shows up and
their ships are sombreros seems kind of
racist Alien Invasion tomato monster
Mexican Armada Brothers I felt a great
disturbance in the force as if millions
of sins suddenly cried out in Terror and
were suddenly silenced it's called Two
Brothers Two Brothers It's just called
two bro I don't know what I like best
about this episode but hearing Justin
Roiland laugh at his own bull might be
the most honest and funniest part but
leaving in the laughter of you cracking
yourself up seems a bit distracting and
over the fourth wall line even for this
show so no this hurts me more than it
hurts you and I'd be on DiCaprio's yacht
banging Kristen Stewart since these
goggles are directly connected of the
DNA of the person watching shouldn't it
disconnect once removed from the scan we
just discovered a show called Ball
fondlers but you guys clearly backed the
wrong conceptual horse yeah but ball
fondlers is just the at you can watch
Regular limited cable to watch that
fakedoors.com is our website this
website doesn't work which seems like a
sin Until you realize it is owned by the
company that owns Rick and Morty so it
could be an inside joke about how just
like the doors and the ad don't open
neither does the website or it could be
because this is an alternate universe so
the website wouldn't exist in this one
like with many Rick and Morty
observations I'm left wondering if it
was accidental oversight or intentional
genius but here's a sin anyway since it
made my head do hurdy brain thinking huh
it's making himself a sandwich now this
top piece of bread has nothing on it
which means he has put the peanut butter
on a slice of bread and then jellied on
top of the peanut butter one ingredient
per slice you monster also he sets the
dirty knife directly on the countertop
and put up with a lot in this world but
people who set dirty utensils on the
counter can go straight to elements
still here
selling fake doors
maybe one of the funniest things they
watch on infinity TV but what kind of
world is it where a guy who sells fake
doors can afford a commercial that runs
90 seconds or longer paid for by trunk
people man the trunk people emblem seems
really offensive but I guess the drunk
people chose that no room is safe from
the turbulent power of turbulent juice
was that a movie or like does it clean
stuff as usual Morty would be amazing at
TV since baby legs you're a good
detective but not good enough because of
your baby legs I'm totally down with a
random Vibe of infinite cable
possibilities but why would baby legs
wear a diaper is this guy an adult but
like a baby can't control when he goes
to the bathroom so I'm partnering you up
with regular legs is everyone with
regular legs named regular legs oh does
this guy's leg Stand Out amongst his
peers as the most regular which would be
a contradiction in terms also this feels
like an average everyday weird cartoon
you can already find on Cartoon Network
it's in the same vein as asy McGee here
we go
that's the sound I make when I'm trying
to run fast this is basically Bennett's
Office boss character and when you're
stealing from 2013 SNL you may want to
rethink your sketch premises that out
there that's my grave wow those graves
are so freshly dug and moundy but it's
pretty incredible no one from this
family has stumbled upon them these
graves are more obvious than the ones
are on Perlman Sees at the end of The
Last Supper nobody exists on purpose
nobody belongs anywhere everybody's
gonna die come watch TV we have 2019 or
a movie this would be the tagline on the
poster 2019. Mrs Sullivan always planned
to leave everything to her cat I
understand this is infinite cable but
why does Rick somehow always end up on a
movie trailer rather than simply a movie
oh Mrs oh Sullivan wow this movie is
G-rated what does it need to even get to
a PG not to mention R but I imagine in
their world Gaspar Noah finds ways to
push the envelope I guess Jerry ate
someone else's toe because all his toes
are intact in the shot while this
reflection in the bird cage gives us a
perfect image of a sad Beth the
reflection in itself seems completely
impossible given the POV and it doesn't
even appear to reflect the cage itself
oh come on as if the odds weren't
astronomical enough that they would even
land on anything about themselves both
Jerry and Beth happen to land on the
same reality I've never stopped thinking
about what might have been wow a pretty
unexpected heartfelt whammy at the end
of this episode full of Randomness this
show is so good
you want me to give you the number of a
different cable company that can oh wait
where it aren't we will you please not
marry me I choose Veronica but imagine
if he came back with something actually
useful for the girl and then he came
back two minutes later with some
self-respect and some dignity but one of
us is dead corn ah no the corn
Paul Newman's gonna have my legs broke
this is delicious you eat pieces for
breakfast it says you can't eat anymore
nobody comes down and buys a car for me
the next hour I'm going to Club this
baby seal that's right I'm gonna come
and seal the [ __ ] better deal no I'll
do it too cause I'm crazy man woman and
now trunk men now you must be out of
your mind if you think I'm gonna get in
this dirty ass trunk hi I'm a trunk
person